veamos cómo utilizar la ecuación de
arrhenius para encontrar la energía de
activación de una reacción en este
ejemplo nuestra reacción es la hizo
meditación de metil isocianato que lo
tenemos del lado izquierdo y se
transforma en el y somero acetonitrilo
esta es una reacción de primer orden y
aquí tenemos las diferentes constantes
de velocidad a diferentes temperaturas
supongamos que no tenemos las últimas
dos columnas de la derecha por ahora
solo tomemos en cuenta la constante de
velocidad a las diferentes temperaturas
en el inciso a nos piden encontrar la
energía de activación en kilo jules por
mol una forma es usar la siguiente
versión de la ecuación de arrhenius que
vimos en el vídeo anterior logaritmo
natural de la constante de velocidad k
es igual a menos
sobre r donde el pan es la energía de
activación y r es la constante de los
gases
1 sobre la temperatura más el logaritmo
natural de a que es el factor de
frecuencia y dijimos que esta forma
corresponde a la ecuación ye igual a mx
más b ye es igual a mx más b entonces si
gráfica mos el logaritmo natural de la
constante de velocidad esto nos debe de
quedar en el eje g y 1 sobre la
temperatura nos queda en el eje x al
final obtendremos una línea recta cuya
pendiente m es igual a menos e iu sobre
r entonces si conocemos la pendiente
podemos obtener la energía de activación
y si quisiéramos obtener el factor de
frecuencia sabemos que la intersección
en el eje que es igual a logaritmo
natural de a entonces si ponemos el
logaritmo natural de la constante de
velocidad en él
jeje esto es lo que pondremos en el eje
g y 1 sobre la temperatura la pondremos
en el eje x me adelanté con los cálculos
para ahorrar tiempo pero lo que hice fue
simplemente sacar el logaritmo natural
de esta constante de velocidad para
obtener este valor y después al dividir
uno entre esta temperatura obtenemos
este valor así que ya tenemos nuestros
datos y ahora vamos a meterlos en la
calculadora para encontrar la pendiente
en esta calculadora vamos a apretar mod
después el número dos para seleccionar
está y después apretamos la tecla número
dos para seleccionar el tipo de ecuación
a más bx entonces seleccionamos esa
opción y ahora podemos tabular nuestros
datos
nuestra x1 es igual a cero punto cero
entonces cuando x es igual a 0.0021 3g
es igual a menos 9.757 ahora vamos con
los siguientes valores x es igual a 0.00
2008 y que es igual a menos 8.903
nuestra siguiente x es igual a 0.00 204
y que es igual a menos 8 puntos 0 79
después tenemos 0.00 200g menos 7.292
finalmente tenemos 0.00 196 y menos 6.5
muy bien una vez que ya tenemos todos
los datos en la calculadora regresamos
al inicio y ahora apretamos la tecla
shift para seleccionar la opción stat de
la tecla número 1 seleccionamos la
opción de regresión con la tecla número
7 la pendiente en la calculadora está
representada con la letra b
entonces b es igual a menos 19.149 y la
intersección de la recta en el eje g es
igual a 30.900 89 entonces vamos a
escribir lo que es igual a m que es
igual a menos 19.149 x
ve que es de 30.900 89 entonces queremos
encontrar la energía de activación así
que nos interesa la pendiente que es
igual a menos 19.149 y aquí ha graficado
todos los puntos como pueden ver tenemos
el logaritmo natural de la constante de
velocidad acá en el eje y 1 sobre la
temperatura en el eje x y estos son
nuestros 5 puntos de datos que pusimos
en la calculadora así que la pendiente
de esta recta la pendiente es igual a
menos 19.149
y para encontrar la energía de
activación sabemos que la pendiente m
voy a cambiar de color la pendiente m es
igual a e
sobre r entonces menos 19.149 es igual a
menos la energía de activación sobre la
constante de los gases que es igual a
8.314 entonces calculemos la energía de
activación 19.149 por 8.314 la energía
de activación es de aproximadamente 159
mil 205 jules formol pero nuestra
respuesta debe estar en kilos urss por
mol
así que la energía de activación es de
159 kilos por mol vamos a escribir la
energía de activación es
igual a 159 kilos jules por mol entonces
usamos todos los datos que nos dieron
para calcular la energía de activación
en kilo yours por mol en el inciso b nos
piden calcular la energía de activación
en kilo yours formol pero esta vez solo
debemos usar las constantes de velocidad
a 470 y 510 kelvin así que podemos usar
otra forma de la ecuación de arrhenius
que vimos en el vídeo anterior logaritmo
natural de la constante de velocidad 2
sobre la constante de velocidad 1 es
igual a menos
a sobre r
es la energía de activación por 1 sobre
t 2 - 1 sobre t 1 la temperatura de 510
es nuestra t 2 y 470 es nuestra t 1
entonces nos queda que el logaritmo
natural en un momento buscamos las
constantes de velocidad es igual a menos
la energía de activación que es lo que
buscamos sobre la constante de los gases
que es igual a 8.314 por 1 sobre textos
que ya dijimos es igual a 510 entonces
sobre 510 menos 1 sobre t 1 que es de
470 entonces uno sobre 470
ahora busquemos los valores de k1 y k2 a
470 y 510 kelvin respectivamente si
regresamos a nuestra tabla a 470 que es
nuestra t1 este es el valor que
corresponde a la constante de velocidad
a 1 y después tenemos de 2 que es igual
a 510 así que la constante de velocidad
2 es igual a 1.45 por 10 a la menos 3
pongamos estos datos en la ecuación
datos sobre cada uno nos queda logaritmo
natural de 1.45 por 10 a la menos 3 /
5.79 por 10 a la menos 5 calculemos el
valor de la energía de activación del
lado derecho
tenemos logaritmo natural de 1.45 por 10
a la menos 3
/ 5.79 por 10 a 5 esto es igual a 3.221
entonces del lado izquierdo nos queda
3.221 y del lado derecho tenemos menos y
al sobre 8.300 14 y vamos a simplificar
esta parte tenemos 1 entre 510 menos 1
entre 470 esto es igual a vamos a
redondear lo menos 1.67 por 10 a la
menos 4 entonces tenemos menos 1.67 por
10 a la menos 4 y finalmente obtengamos
la energía de activación
tenemos 3.221
por 8.300 14 entre 1.67 por 10 a la
menos 4 la energía de activación es de
aproximadamente 160 kilos urss por mol
recuerden que necesitamos la respuesta
en kilos urss por mol no en yours por
mol
entonces la energía de activación es
igual a 160 kilos jules por mol que es
muy cercano al valor que obtuvimos con
la otra forma de la ecuación de
arrhenius aquí obtuvimos 159 kilos urss
por mol
así que ustedes pueden usar la forma que
quieran todo depende de los datos que
les den en el problema